نريد ان نستودع حقيقه ما يحدث الان معك
السيده هاله حول
المساعدات الامريكيه تحديدا هل وصلت هذه
المساعدات اين وصلت ولمن تقدمه
شكرا جزيلا على الاستضافه وقبل ما نبدا
لازم اقدم تعزينا للشعب التركي لسفير
التركي ولشعب السوري نحن كلنا نرى هذه
الصور والصعب جدا
كامسانه يعني صعب جدا نرى هذه الصور وكل
الشعب الامريكي كله مع الشعب التركي
وسوريا الان وبالنسبه للدعم الامريكي في
نقطتين هنا
منذ منذ بدايه الحرب الولايات المتحده
تدعم سوريا والشعب السوري ادعمنا الشعب
السوري باكثر من 15 مليار دولار في دعم
انساني وفي هذه السنه ارسلنا كثير من
الدعم الانساني ولذلك عندما حصل الزلزال
المنظمه غير حكوميه كان عندهم دعم من
الولايات المتحده دعم من دعم مساعدات
الغذائي مساعدات الصحي وكذلك مساعدات
للاماكن للحمايه
بعد الزلزال اخذوا هذا الدعم الامريكي
واستعملوه
ليساعدوا الشعب السوري على طول مباشره
بوقت سريع جدا هذه اول نقطه انه كان في
دعم امريكي داخل البلد وهذا استعمل تحديدا
ملتزمه بالشعب السوري وبشعب وبدعم الشعب
التركيه الاثنين وارسلنا فراق بعثوا
الانقاذ الى تركيا ولكن كذلك ارسلنا اليات
وادويات ادويات للحفر
ومختصين الاليات مختصين بالبحث والانقاذ
وهذا راحل تركيا وكذلك الى سوريا وايضا
ارسلنا متخصصين في البحث والانقاذ
كثير من الخبراء مثلا مهندسين
مسعفين كذلك
وهؤلاء
المتخصصين روحيل تركيا وكذلك الى سوريا
بعد الزلزال يساعد الشعب السوري ومن تاكيد
انه الوكاله الامريكيه الدوليه للتنميه
ستلعن ستعلن باكثر دعم للشعب السوري
وللشعب التركي في القادمه لان مع الاسف
الكارثه وكله يغير يوم يوم ورا يوم
والولايات المتحده ملتزمه بالدعم الشعبين
في هذه الكارثه
الى اين وصلت هذه المساعدات تحديدا في
الاراضي السوريه
بالنسبه لتحديدا ممكن اقول في الاماكن
لمحتها
للناس محتاجينها ولكن بالسبب امنيه لا
يمكنني اقول
بفين بالضبط ولكن وزير بلانكين قال امس في
مؤتمر صحفي مع ناذره منيته من حلف النيتو
قال في المؤتمر انه هؤلاء الخبراء راحوا
الى الاثنين سوريا وتركيا هذه هذه
المعلومات اللي عندنا
وبالتاكيد انه الشعب السوري يعرف انه
الولايات المتحده تقف جانب الشعب السوري
الان مثل خلال سنوات الاخيره خلال منذ طول
الايام الحرب نحن نعمل كل في جهودنا وكما
قلت الوكاله الامريكيه للتنميه الدوليه
يوسع اي دي هي هذه الوكاله مسؤوله بكل
المساعدات ولكن كمان عندها تنسيق مع
الاتحاد الاوروبي مع امم المتحده مع كثير
من المنظمات غير حكوميه داخل سوريا
وكذلك مع الجيش الامريكي في اوروبا يعني
كل التنسيق
لنبحث كل طرق الايجابيه للوصول الدعم الى
تركيا الى سوريا ويلا تركيا اذا كنت فهمت
كلامك بشكل صحيح
قد تكون هذه المساعدات وصلت الى المناطق
التي لا يسيطر عليها النظام او تسيطر
عليها
المعارضه ولكن تصريحات التي تاتي من هناك
ربما تشير الى عكس ذلك تماما بانه لا
مساعدات وصلت حتى الان اذا ما اخذنا بهذا
الامر بهذا الشكل وعدم تحديدك للجهه التي
وصلت اليها
المساعدات الامريكيه الان هل يعني ذلك ان
هناك من يعرقل وصول هذه المساعدات الدوليه
من اي طرف كان الى الاراضي السوريه سيده
هاله ومن هي هذه الجهه
انا ممكن اكون واضحه جدا في هذا السؤال
الولايات المتحده تشتغل مع المنظمات غير
حكوميه داخل سوريا والمنظمات غير حكوميه
داخل سوريا يشتغلوا في كل اماكن داخل
سوريا مثلا
حوار البيضاء تشتغل في كل الاماكن ليس فقط
في اماكن
من غير النظام
والخود البيضاء تروح لفين الناس محتاجينها
والولايات المتحده تدعم سواد البيضاء
ومنظمه غير حكوميه اخره ولكن الولايات
المتحده لا
نواصل اي دعم بالشكل تماما الى النظام لان
نحن نعرفه من كل الايام كل السنوات
الاخيره انه ليس هناك اي ثقه في النظام
اذا ادعم يروح الى النظام
سيكون فساد سيكون صرك ولازم نفكره انه
النظ مستعمل اسلحه كيماويه ضد الشعب
السوري والان الولايات المتحده
تشوف طرق فعليه ايجابيه كيف ممكن تساعدوه
الشعب السوري بالشكل قوي والشكل الفعالي
ولذلك نحن نشتغل مع المنظمات غير حكوميه
داخل سوريا في كل في وهما عندهم اماكن
عندهم
ايجابيات روحوا المكان المهمه داخل سوريا
ونحن عندنا ثقه وعلاقه قويه مع هذه
المنظمات غير حكوميه ونحن نواصل الدعم
لهذه المنظمات النظام السوري يقول بان
قانون العقوبات يعيق وصول هذه المساعدات
للسوريين بشكل عام سواء كان يراد النظام
او في غيرها كيف تردون وتعلقون على هذا
الامر زيدان
مع الاسف هذا كلام النظام السوري ولكن في
دليل نرى انه
طيارات وعلى اخري
روحوا الى دمشق يعني في كثير من البلدان
اختاروا دعم الى الى الحكومه الى النظام
الاسد ليس هناك اي تاثير من الحكومه
الامريكيه ليس هناك اي رد الفعل من
الحكومه الامريكيه
القانون
العقوبات واضحه واضحه جدا منذ سنوات انه
الدعم الانساني ليس هناك اي تاثير على
الدعم الانساني بالنسبه للعقوبات في
استثناءات لدعم الانساني لدعم الغذائي او
الصحي او على اخر كل الدعم الانساني هناك
استثناءات تحت العقوبات وفي دليل انه
يواصل دعم للنظام والولايات المتحده ليس
عملت اي شيء ضد هذه البلدان
طرق طريق النظام
ما هي المعابر التي تستخدمونها لايصال هذه
المساعدات للسوريين سيده هاله كل
المعلومات الان منذ بدايه هذه الازمه وحتى
الان تشير الى عدم جاهزيه مثلا معبر باب
الهوى لاسباب متعلقه
باللوجستيه متعلقه مثلا بدمار يحيط في هذا
المعبر في تصريحات اخرى تقول بان هذا
المعبر جاهز هناك معابر اخرى مثل السلام
والراعي كذلك من يقول بانها جاهزه هل هذه
هي المعابر التي تدخل من خلالها المساعدات
الامريكيه وغير الامريكيه وهل يتم التنسيق
مع الدول الاخرى الراغبه في تقديم
مساعداتها للسوريين خاصه في الاراضي التي
لا يسيطر عليها النظام
صحيح انه الزلزال كان عنده تاثير كبير على
المعابر وعلى باب الهواء وهذه كانت مشكله
كبيره
وعلى طول الولايات المتحده كانت على اتصال
وفي التنسيق مع الامم المتحده والشركاء في
الارض في الارض الواقع وكذلك مع الاتحاد
الاوروبي كان في تنسيق قوي لنبحث على على
الطرق الفعاليه اللي ممكن الدعم يدخل
وبالنسبه للولايات المتحده ومع تنسيق مع
المنظمات غير حكوميه داخل سوريا كنا نبحث
على اي جهه ممكن الدعم يدخل ولكن سمعنا
اليوم من الامم المتحده اخبار ايجابي انه
الامم المتحده
حصلت الدعم
عبر باب الهوى اليوم او المره من بدايه
بعد الزلزال وهذا كان خبر جيد جدا ولكن
بالنسبه للولايات المتحده هذه النقطه
نحن كنا نكلمها من سنوات انه لازم توسيع
الحدود لازم توسيع المعابر الحدود
لسعد السوريين والنظام مع الاسف كل هذه
سنوات كان ضد هذا ولكن هذه النقطه مهمه
الولايات المتحده دائما تشجع توسيع الحدود
في شمال
لمساعده للسوريين من ينسق عمل
الخبراء والمختصين ومساله ايصال المساعدات
يعني طرف امريكي موجود على الارض هل
السفاره او القنصليه في تركيا عادت لعملها
لانه هناك معلومات تتحدث عن اغلاق السفاره
قبل اسبوع من الان تقريبا وصححي لي هذا
الامر بسبب دواعي امنيه
الرئيس بايدن عين السمان هي مديره وكاله
الامريكيه الدوليه للتاميه هي المسؤوله
قائده
لتنسيق كل الدعم للولايات المتحده
لمساعدات لسوريا وهي تشتغل مع كل الجهات
المعنيه داخل الحكومه الامريكيه لان فيه
جهات كثيره داخل الحكومه الامريكيه ليس
فقط الوكاله ولكن الخارجيه الوزارات
الدفاع يعني الفراق البحث والانقاذ جو من
ولايه كاليفورنيا وولايه فرجينيا هذا يظهر
انه كل الولايات المتحده تعمل كل في
جهودها
لوصول الدعم للولايات المثاليه لسوريا
وكذلك
في تركيا ابوابها العدد لمتابعه اعمالها
حتى
بالنسبه للمعلومات اللي انا عندي ممكن
ارجع لك بالتاكيد بهذا ولكن بالنسبه
للمعلومات اللي عندي
السفاره ليس مغلوقه للسفاره بتشتغل
والسفير هو لقبل صفر سفير امريكي في في
انقره في في تركيا هو اللي استقبل الفراق
البحث والانقاذ اللي وصلوا من امريكا اذا
المشاهدين يريدون
يشوفوا ويرى الصور للبحث
للفراط بحث الانقاذ ممكن يروحوا الى تويتر
يشوفوا الصور للفراط بحث والانقاذ
الامريكي لوصل الى تركيا وكل الاليات اكثر
من
كيلو جرام من اليات ليساعدوا بالفحر
ليساعدوا بالبحث والانقاذ والولايات
المتحده كما قلت نحن نعمل كل في جهودنا
والشعب التركي والشعب السوري وفعلا قلوبنا
مع مع شعبان شكرا لك من دبي هاله غريت
المتحدثه باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه